bienvenidos de nuevo aquí estoy
adelantando me un poquito hice esta
tabla para que no pierdas nada de tu
tiempo en lo que me veas hacer esta
tabla por lo tanto me adelanté a ponerle
aquí ahorita te explico por qué estamos
en el siguiente problema estamos en el
problema número 17 y el problema número
17 tiene que ver con una tienda de
relojes y dice más o menos así
un comerciante vende tres tipos de
relojes el reloj tipo am el reloj tipo
ven y el reloj tipo c cuyo timbrado está
indicado según el tipo de reloj y se
muestra en la siguiente tabla ahorita te
explico la tabla cuál es el número total
de veces que suena el timbre en la
tienda de relojes en un periodo de 90
minutos desde las siete y cuarto desde
las siete con quince minutos hasta las
ocho con cuarenta y cinco minutos
a las ocho con cuarenta y cinco minutos
y bueno aquí tenemos tres tipos de
relojes el reloj
el reloj y el boxeo y en la tienda hay
diez relojes tipo am hay cinco relojes
tiempo y hay tres relojes tipo c esta es
la cantidad de relojes que hay en la
tienda de cada uno de los tipos ahora
aquí está especificado el timbrado vamos
a ver a qué se refiere con esto el
primero dice el reloj tipo am y el
logotipo ven suena n veces el timbre a
la hora n es decir que cuando son las
siete en punto el reloj para timbrar
siete veces cuando se asocia un punto
del reloj para temblar ocho veces y así
sucesivamente entonces esto es lo que va
a pasar con el reloj y con el reloj sin
embargo el reloj se es un poco menos
ruidoso y solamente timbra una vez cada
hora va a sonar una vez el timbre cada
hora y esto es lo que pasa con el reloj
se ahora date cuenta de lo siguiente
tanto el reloj a como el reloj se
siembran una vez cada media hora suena
el timbre una vez
cada media hora y yo lo que quiero saber
es cuántas veces va a sonar el timbre en
este periodo de tiempo así que pues
vamos a hacerlo con mucho cuidado
pensemos primero en el reloj tipo a
entonces el reloj tipo a si te das
cuenta del reloj tipo ahora tenemos diez
relojes entonces vamos a multiplicar lo
que nos salga por 10 porque tenemos 10
de ellos ya ver vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa con el reloj tipo el reloj tipo
am cuando dan las 7 bueno a las 7 ya
pasaron cuando dan las 8 suena ocho
veces porque el reloj tipo am es del
tipo de relojes que suenan n veces
cuando da la hora n en la hora 8 cuando
dan las 8 va a sonar ocho veces entonces
va a temblar ocho veces entonces ocho
timbres ocho timbres
a las 8 a las 8
esto por una parte pero también por otra
parte date cuenta que suena una vez cada
media hora entonces estamos en las siete
y cuarto llegamos a las siete y media
suena una vez mi reloj llegamos a las
ocho suena ocho veces y después llegamos
hasta las ocho y media y otra vez suena
el reloj tipo up porque una vez cada
media hora va a sonar entonces a esto
hay que sumarle dos veces de dos timbres
de cada media hora dos timbres de la
media hora de las siete y media y de las
ocho y media y lo voy a poner así a las
7 30 va a sonar una vez ya las 8 30 va a
sonar otra vez muy bien eso es lo que
pasa con el reloj tipo am pero
recuerda que son 10 de ellos entonces
esto hay que multiplicarlo por 10 ok
esto es para el reloj tipo a vamos a ver
qué es lo que pasa con el reloj tipo b
lo que suceda con un reloj tipo b fíjate
que lo vamos a tener que multiplicar por
5 porque hay 5 relojes tipo b por lo
tanto vamos a multiplicando por 5 y qué
va a pasar con este reloj bueno pues
este suena n b s es cuando el timbre
llega a la n ahora pero va a pasar por
los 8 entonces va a sonar ocho timbres
ocho timbres cuando llegue timbres
cuando el reloj marque las ocho cuando
el reloj marque las ocho y después ya no
suena nunca más
este reloj tipo ver entonces a esto hay
que multiplicarlo por cinco y ahora
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con el
reloj tipos
el reloj tipo sem tenemos tres de ellos
entonces lo que nos salga lo voy a
multiplicar por tres y el reloj tipo c
era el que no era tan ruidoso suena una
vez cada hora entonces va a sonar una
vez el timbre cuando llegue a las ocho
de la noche a las ocho de la noche ya
esto hay que sumarle a que suena una vez
cada media hora por lo tanto va a sonar
otras dos veces dos timbres más cuando
lleguemos a las siete y media de las 8
no voy a poner con ese mismo color
cuando lleguemos a las 7 30 y cuando
lleguemos a las 8 30 va a sonar también
el reloj tipo c y bueno a esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la cantidad de relojes
que hay del tipo sé que son tres
entonces a esto lo voy a multiplicar por
tres muy bien y cuánto me va a salir de
todo esto bueno vamos a ver del primer
reloj del reloj tipo am son ocho timbres
más dos timbres por 10-8 timbres a las
ocho de la noche
+ 23 a las siete y media y las ocho y
media pero son diez relojes de estos
entonces va a ser 8 22 10 10 x 10 son
100 entonces todos los relojes tipo a
van a sonar 100 veces el reloj va a
sonar 8 timbres a las 8 x 5 es decir 40
veces todos los relojes tipo b en total
van a sonar 40 veces mientras que el
reloj se el reloj que se va a sonar un
timbre 28 y dos timbres a las siete y
media y ocho treinta entonces uno más
dos son tres por tres son nueve entonces
nueve veces y en total cuantas veces van
a sonar estos tres tipos de relojes de
las siete y cuarto a las 8 45 pues bueno
va a ser 100 más 40 más 9 lo cual me da
49 149 149 timbrazos va a haber entre
las siete y cuarto y las 8 45 en este
lugar en esta tienda de relojes y ya
está esa es la solución de este problema
así que vámonos
el último problema de este examen tipo 2
sección número 6 vámonos al problema 18
y que me va a decir y dice tenemos 5
tarjetas y no creo que sea muy
conveniente poner las 5 tarjetas así que
mejor vamos a poner 5 letras es mucho
más fácil tengo la letra am la letra be
la letra c la letra be y la letra i
tengo estas cinco letras y bueno estas
cinco letras las vamos a ordenar en una
fila las tarjetas mostradas abajo se
acomodan en una fila de tal manera que
una de ellas vamos a suponer la hace de
tal manera que ese nunca puede quedar en
un extremo de la fila se nunca puede
quedar en un extremo y la pregunta es
cuántos arreglos tengo con estas cinco
tarjetas ok
común son letras en lugares de tarjetas
voy a poner aquí hace
sé qué pasa con ella bueno se es la que
está restringida se solamente tiene de
tres posibilidades déjame poner aquí los
lugares de la fila tengo este lugar es
la fila este lugar de la fila este lugar
de la fila este otro y este otro y si te
das cuenta que solamente puede ocupar
este lugar o este lugar o este lugar no
puede ocupar ninguno de los extremos por
lo tanto pensemos en sem hice solamente
se puede acomodar en tres lugares
entonces tres lugares por ahora vamos a
fijarnos en la anp tiene cuantas
posibilidades bueno si se queda aquí o
aquí o acá a solamente va a tener cuatro
espacios disponibles o este oeste o este
oeste o depende de donde que deseen pero
como se ya está acomodada entonces a
solamente tiene cuatro posibles lugares
y qué pasa cómo ve pues bella tiene más
restricciones se está en alguno de estos
lugares a está en otro lugar entonces
ves solamente le quedan tres lugares por
escoger ven tiene tres lugares dispone
y dime qué va a pasar con de bueno ya
está acumulado ha ya está acomodado ven
ya está acumulado se de solamente tiene
dos lugares disponibles entonces de
tiene dos lugares disponibles y en ahí
lo vamos a poner en el último lugar de
esta fila entonces solamente tiene un
lugar disponible y cuantos esto bueno 3
por 4 12 12 por tres es 36 36 por dos es
72 72 por unas 72 tenemos 72 distintos
arreglos con estas 5 tarjetas o bueno
cuando estas cinco letras con la
restricción de que esta letra no puede
quedar en uno de los extremos y ya está
hemos acabado la sección número seis
este era el último problema de la
sección número seis así que vamos a
vernos en el siguiente vídeo donde vamos
a empezar una nueva sección nos vemos
pronto